the u.n security council will hold an
emergency meeting today to discuss the
african nation of sudan where there's
been a military coup there are new
protests this morning after thousands of
protesters took to the streets to
denounce the coup at least seven people
were killed according to a health
ministry official roxanna saberi is
monitoring the developments from london
[Applause]
protesters are marching in the streets
of khartoum chanting freedom and burning
barricades acts of defiance that
activists say led to this
this man says the country's armed forces
fired stun grenades then live ammunition
at demonstrators like him
they're demanding a return to civilian
rule after sudan's military mounted a
coup yesterday and detained the prime
minister
coup leader general abdel fatah berhan
announced that political infighting
pushed the military to act and that it
would hang on to power until elections
are held in 2023
the coup is threatening sudan's fragile
transition to democracy
in 2019 a revolution ousted longtime
dictator omar al-bashir and forced the
military to share power with civilian
leaders until elections could be held
the compromise helped sudan end decades
of international isolation the u.s
removed it from its list of state
sponsors of terrorism and just last
weekend a u.s envoy met with a now
ousted prime minister in a show of
support
now washington is freezing 700 million
dollars in aid civilian-led transitional
government should be immediately
restored
it represents the will of the sudanese
people as evidenced by the significant
peaceful demonstrations
sudan had already seen several coup
attempts in the past two and a half
years including one just last month it's
still unclear where the military has
detained the prime minister after
yesterday's coup there's been no word
from him tony
roxanna savari in london for us roxanna
thank you very much